*happy flute music plays*
[Ethan] Fuckin' go!
WWPSH! Hehehehe.
[Slurring and lisping] Top of the morning to ya, laddies!
I jusht got back from the dentisht, and no they didn't
give me laughing gas...
they gave me a bunch of novocaine and my
whole mouth is completely numb. I can't feel anything.
I can't feel anything
at all. So, I'm also sick so it's
it'sh a whole smorgasbord of
dilemmash in my face right
now. * Deep inhale*  Anyway!
we, today, are going to try to get
out the twelve days of Chrishtmash and
then, uh, unfortunately everybody in the
room is also sick.
I have infected everybody.
It feels like my lipsh are completely shwollen
but they're not, are they?
No, they're not. As soon as Tyler
gets back, we're gonna record a little sketch.
*Sucks in saliva* The sequel to your video. *Laughter*
Right now, life is a traveshty and everything in
existence is pain.  The univershe is a cruel
mishtressh who doesn't enjoy the company of
othersh. So as we wallow in sorrow for all
eternity, we will find that life is a vacuous void.
*Giggles* I can't feel my nose or my lips.
This is weird 'cause I feel my hairs... but not the
skin under it. Anyway...
I think that's all for now. Here comes that sketch!
*loud sucking noise*
*music cuts*
*Ethan screaming*
No. He's DOING IT AGAIN!!!
TYLER!!!
[Tyler] WHAT!!!
HE"S DOING IT AGAIN!
[Tyler] OH NO!!! lets-letsgethim...
We's gots ta stop him *Gun clicks*
I thought we warned you the first time
there tiny tim. Septiplier's dead...
*click*
[Ethan] NO!
[Ethan] no..
[Ethan] Septiplier's always real!! I told you this the last time!!
[Mark] It's deadd!! It's deadd!!
[Mark] Wait. wait. We can't do this again. We can't
do the exact same thing we've done again
[Ethan] We have to settle this like real men.
[Singing in unison] I am special, I am special.
Yes I am, yes I am. I am very special
*Mark stops singing and starts screaming into his hands*
Everybody go over the top on this one.
[Tyler] Okay.
[Mark] It's gotta be good.
No. NO. TYLER! He's doing it again.
[Tyler] What?! I'm Tyler's Let's get him!
[Mark] Let's get him!
[Tyler] Let's get that son of a... bluebird! What are you doing here!?
[Mark] You sack of shit.
I thought we TOLB YOU DA FIRT TIME
[Tyler] They're not together. They'll never be together!
[Ethan] NO!!!!! IT WILL BE REAL
[Tyler] Never!
[Mark] NEVER. No! No!
[Ethan] We can't do this again!
We CAN'T DO THIS again! We've got to settle this like Ben.
[Mark] Like Ben?
[Tyler] Who's Ben?
[Mark] Like Big Ben?
[Tyler] Big Ben.
[Mark] I remember Ben.
I am special, I am special. Yes I am, yes I am.  I am very special.
I am very special. Yes I am.
[Ethan] Fucking Christ... *giggles*
[Mark] Oh no.
[Ethan *while giggling *]  One more time from the top.
[Mark] One more time! Here we go!
Hey, Kathryn,  you need to -- you need to film
better so this is funny.
No. No! NO!!! He's doing it again!
You're doing it again.
[Ethan] No, no.
[Mark] I thought I warned you. Septiplier's DEAD.
[Ethan] No, NO NO!
[Tyler] We gotta plunge it out of him!
[Mark] OHH my god.
[Ethan] NO STOP! PLEASE!
[Mark] Plunge. Plunge him! Plunge him!
[Ethan] LISTEN TO ME! LISTEN TO ME!
[Mark] Huh?
[Ethan] We'll settle this!
We'll settle this like real men. No. Stop.
Put everything down and stayy- NO! STAY calm
*Tyler giggling*
*Tyler is steadily laughing*
[Mark] What are -- what are you doing?  What -- what -- what -- Ethan?
[Mark] Ethan, I'm - I'm confused and aroused....
I know what we're doing.
[Ethan] I am special... *dissolves into laughter*
*Tyler gasps*
There's gotta be one drop of comedy somewhere.
No! NO!! He's doing it again.
You're doing it again. Septiplier is DEAD
[Ethan] We talked about this.
IT'S STILL ALIVE IN MY HEART!
[Mark] Oh, we talked about it all right.
[Tyler] We gotta plunge it out of him.
[Ethan] No. NO.
[Mark] Plunge that dirty mind outta ya!
[Ethan] We can... UH... we can settle this!
We can settle this like men!
[Ethan] Put everything down.
[Mark] What?
[Tyler] Wait.
[Mark] What are you doing?
[Tyler] What? What?
[Ethan] *Trying not to laugh*
[Mark] Don't...
[Singing] I am special, I am special. Yes I am, yes I am. I am very special.
I am very special.
[Mark] I'm bailing, I can't do this. This is never going up.
nope. nuh-uh. This is not funny. We're draining -- we drained all
the funny out of it. Ah was - we had a good time
guys, we have fun and that's all that
matters, right?
[Ethan] Right.
Hi. I'm back now. I -- I -- I'm better than I
was because most of my face is back
under my control. Except my bottom lip, which is
still numb.  I wanted to say, because I
didn't say it before,  because I was totally
out of my mind, that the twelve days of
Christmas is still going to be happening.
We're still gonna be getting them out
but it's going to be delayed. We're working
very hard on it right now, as you can see
right here we've got this exclusive...
listen, h-here we go, aha.
[Vocal track] *loud noises that distantly resemble trumpeting*
Well there you...
[Vocal track] (unintelligible)-you gonna get the other guy, then he's gonna shoot em all
[Vocal track] and we're all gonna die!
*mouth sounds reach climax in "music"*
[Vocal Track] OH NO HE GOTTA GUN! And he's gonna shoot you up in your face!
*barely containing laughter* So yeah, this was the music to the
sketch that didn't get used. But, uh, we're working very
hard in the office. *cracks up*
So anyway, thank you--
Um, where's this going? Is it at the end? At the beginning? I don't know. Fuckin i - its
It's comin'. Bye. Fuck.